[музика]
кожен хто донатить Україні може отримати
від нас активку
[музика]
коли навколо тебе палає світ закохані
можуть стати або чужими або останньою
опорою одне для одного я Анна Жуковець
авторка трек іст
[музика]
єдине що давало мені сили пережити цей
час і вижити це Мій партнер Мій друг
мені не треба було багато говорити з ним
він розумів мене бо теж має
пострадянське минуле Мені пощастило Але
багато закоханих в Україні цього немає
їхній партнера був в іншій країні або на
фронті або військовополонений або
загинув
Діма вирішили зрозуміти що війна робить
із коханням
[музика]
любов
усім Привіт моє ім'я інгрет я українська
співачка і коли Російська Федерація
напала на мою країну я вимушена була
переїхати до Берліну це
так склалось обставини що я зустріла під
час війни своє кохання і він військовий
про це і буде наступна історія
[музика]
Всі мої пісні про любов для мене Це
найвища точка почуттів я про це і
пишуть
Берліні Ми зняли кліп який скоро вийде і
дуже багато творчих є проектів над якими
я зараз працюю
[музика]
ти меч
тала як я познайомилась зі своїм хлопцем
він завітав до мене на концерт я його не
знала він просто мене побачив в Ютубі в
рекомендованих і вирішив прийти до мене
на концерт і потім він зайшов до нас в
гримерку подарував мені квіти і також ми
познайомились
а потім ми почали спілкуватися в
Інстаграмі не пам'ятали що він
військовий і коли почалась війна і я
почала йому писати Ну що ви там Як ви
там Як Київ як взагалі ситуація і ми на
цій темі почали спілкуватись
спілкуватися спілкуватися
[музика]
і я Просто відчула що це моя людина що
він мені рідний що я хочу з ним
продовжувати спілкуватися і хочу з ним
побачитись
[музика]
Я просто медленно
умирала и ждала не верила просто жилам
желаю я существовала
надежде что как-то як я рухаюсь в житті
він теж не знає вдома яка є
і потім я зрозуміла що я хочу поїхати в
Україну тому що в мене є почуття до
нього
Я стою на вокзалі і тут мені дівчата
говорять ззаді він ззаду інгрет іде
як ми оці два різних світа комунікуємо
разом я знаю що таке військове життя і
батько мене військовий я дивилася як
мама там так з татом спілкуються тобто
для мене війна почалась не
24 лютого
[музика]
я про це не питаюсь
так мені якісь страхіття розкажуть а
потім вони поїдуть туди то що я ж буду
собі малювати картинки як там і Мені
здається це все ж таки трошки йшов в мою
психіку урівноважити і щоб лишній раз
про це все не говорити коротше після
війни
[музика]
коли почалась війна у всіх Було відчуття
що ми кинули свою країну і приїхали сюди
А як там люди в Україні а ми тут але
коли я з ним переписувалась то він мені
трошки згладжував це він говорив все
нормально ти поїхала тому що тобі
потрібно теж розвиватися тобі потрібно
жити
за мною
пливе пливе моя доню Дніпром заводу ти
випливи русалкою завтра серед ночі ніхто
вже проще Просто
казалась ти в морі а ти ліжко Я думала
Вечность тебя ждать готовы но пару
неделю не хватило солна
у мене стоїть додаток повітряної тривоги
досі для мене дуже важливо їздити в
Україну Я дуже часто туди назад туди
назад Якщо б я була постійно в Берліні Я
думаю що можливо би трошечки в нас
ну
була така що я не розумію як там до
кінця так а він не розуміє як тут гори
[музика]
щоби не погасло і стіні прекрасно горить
сонце Красне
горить
Сонце
це я Ну це я обрала для себе так ну типу
я це розумію
що я розумію що я за нього буду
хвилюватися постійно що навіть якщо
закінчиться війна як це військові не
сплять
[музика]
Чи ми з ним розмовляли чи що він помре
ну ні Ми не говоримо а що буде якщо ти
помреш
я йому не дозволяю про таке говорити
[музика]
я
ліпше буду направляти свою енергію на
наше спільне майбутнє були Деякі моменти
типу але я йому не дозволяю я тобі
запрещаю говорити про це сьогодні я
Отпускаю тебя я
[музика]
думаю У той час як інгрет має можливість
відвідувати свого хлопця в Україні Олена
навіть не знає чи живий її чоловік
встання Олена бачила чоловіка у квітні
2022 року відтоді військовий перебуває у
російському полоні які Близько трьох
тисяч українців та українок Репортер
трек Іст Кріс Бобін зустрівся з Оленою в
Києві щоб дізнатися як вона це витримує
І що полон робить із коханням
[музика]
амінки Я у Києві на батьківщині моїх
дідуся і бабусі і я тут щоб зустрітися з
колишніми військовополоненими серед них
українська військова Олена яка вийшла з
російської в'язниці але її Випробування
ще не закінчилися
для українських військовополонених які
зараз благополучно повернулися додому
їхня боротьба полягає не лише вдома щоб
подолати травму після ув'язнення триває
боротьба за те щоб їхні побратими які
все ще перебувають у російських
в'язницях також повернулися додому А в
деяких випадках всі побратими ще й їхні
кохання люди
[музика]
[оплески]
звати Олена Мені 27 років а мій
військовий шлях почався з 2016 року коли
я закінчила медичний коледж і прибула до
лав збройних сил України на посаду
бойового медика в 36 окремо бригада
морської піхоти це для того щоб рятувати
життя і намагатися допомогти своїй
країні у збройній агресії проти Росії
ми з моїм чоловіком Андрієм
познайомилися на службі він той час
виконував обов'язки мого прямого
командира А ми закохалися і так
створилися наші відносини потім Це
переросло у шлюб
наразі на сьогоднішній день Ми разом уже
майже 6 років
[музика]
лютого 2022 року ми з моїм підрозділам
як завжди виконували
бойове завдання в
передмісті Маріуполя після 24 лютого
Наша команда прийняли рішення
переміститися нашими підрозділу на завод
імені Ілліча в самому місці Маріуполь
Там ми
переховувалися і виконували бойове
завдання Але з кожним днем
ставало все гірше і
кожен день ми втрачали людей втрачали
сили і втрачали надію було прийнято
рішення
здаватись в полон або виходити з заводу
ми прийняли рішення з моїм чоловіком
вийти з заводу і намагатись прорватися
хоча ми розуміли що
нас оточено
[музика]
через руїни Маріуполя Олена і її чоловік
були захоплені російськими військовими
Під прицілом зброї це був останній раз
коли Олена бачила Андрія перед тим як їх
розлучили і відправили у російський
в'язниці
коли вони на захопили вони вивели нас
будинку представили автомати до
голів погрожували і коли нас відводили
я обернулася подивилась на Андрія і не
було змоги йому ще сказати якось
попрощатись вони не дали змоги просто
вони просто мене відвели
дуже швидко і я просто повернулася
подивилася на нього Він на мене і я
думаю ми поглядом сказали один одному
прощай
[музика]
коли нас привезли в оленівку
Я думала там умови дуже погані
не давали одяг теплий хоча було дуже
холодно а камера була розрахована на
двох осіб але нас було 17
і саме в цих умовах Олена дізналася вона
вагітна від Андрія
Олена звільнили через три тижні але
Андрій Який все ще перебуває в
російській в'язниці навіть не підозрює
що він батько
[музика]
мамою
це не складно Це не страшно але в даних
умовах
ну є страх за сина Звичайно є страх що
він не матиме мене нормального дитинства
і я дуже-дуже хочу сповістити І якось
повідомити свого чоловіка що в нього є
син на жаль ми не можемо
добитися від Російської сторони саме
дотримання
правил женевської конвенції в яких
сказано що військовослужбовець має право
на листування
[музика]
Микола юрлов юрист який спеціалізується
на міжнародному гуманітарному праві він
упевнений що у випадку з Оленою та
Андрієм були порушені права людини
обіцяні військовополоненим
[музика]
і Україна і Російська Федерація є
учасниками женевських конвенцій 1949
року та додаткових протоколів до них
і в конкретній описані ситуації
порушуються права Олени та її чоловіка
на листування які прямо передбачені
третьою женевською конвенцією про
військовополонених
[музика]
Женевська конвенція як і звичайна
міжнародне гуманітарне право
передбачають що кожна воююча сторона
повинна забезпечити основні стандарти
поводження з військовополоненими сюди
також входить право на спілкування з
коханими з родичами
людська природа полягає в тому що ми як
соціальні істоти не можемо бути
ізольованими це не по-людськи і
принизливо
[музика]
ситуація Олени не унікальна у Києві вона
зустрічається з іншими військовими з
Маріуполя які були ув'язнені з нею і чиї
чоловіки так само військові досі
перебувають у російському полоні
14 квітня 2022 року по нинішній період
я не можу зв'язатися з чоловіком ні
пізно не через красний крест так голосно
Я його вже не чула 10 місяців і не
бачила особисто каже Тут только Надежда
на реальних это Щасливий білет що наші
хлопці будуть додому Ну так і щоб якось
зірки там склалося
Я тримаюся тільки на тому що мені
потрібно якось витягнути Андрія
стали ваші жінка така от Дівчата а ви
також такі
ми по-своєму ну нас просто не такі
обстоятельства в жизни Ну нам трошки
проще В нас немає в тебе понімаєш ти
маленька Крошечка которую уже которая
блин тоже
пережила таке що вообще
видержать такі психологический
навантаження і фізичні
я переживала за те що він там буде
здоровий чи не здоровий Я дуже боялась
що щось не так потому що я ще не
питалась нормально ці емоції конечно это
Зленко вдвох плакали
будь ласка
[музика]
переживши Маріуполі переживший полон я
зрозуміла Що найголовніше в житті це
здоров'я і
це здоров'я твоїх близьких
місцем дуже життя радісний я показую
йому фотографії батька Я намагаюсь
навчити його казати не тільки мама а і
папа я включаю леону відео де є Андрій
щоб він чув його голос і бачив батька і
я дуже хочу щоб Андрій який дуже сильно
хотів сина щоб він бачив як росте його
дитина
На жаль реальність зовсім інша родичі
позбавлені будь-якого контакту з
близькими Ми також хотіли поспілкуватися
з людьми які знаходяться безпосередньо
на фронті і це зробила моя колега
Кароліна постійнова Я хотіла дізнатися
що відбувається з коханням коли ви разом
воюєте на передовій як Олександр І
насправді Спершу ми просто хотіли
поговорити через Zoom але потім він мені
сказав що наступного дня вони повинні
їхати в зону бойових дій і ми вирішили
що знімати потрібно й там
[музика]
Привіт мене звати Олександр жуган Мені
38 років і я був викладачем драми
драматургом актором і режисером зараз є
солдат мінометної батареї та
[музика]
ун get to talk about ви не можете
говорити про свої почуття партнеру це
найважче тому що я думаю що ми сильно
змінилися і я думаю що якщо ви не
перевіряєте Чи ви та сама людина чи
сильно ви змінилися це впливає на ваші
стосунки
Ви повинні боротися щоб вижити Ви
повинні боротися щоб зберегти свою
культуру захистити тих кого любите
ти ніби замерзаєш ціпанієш коли Справа
доходить до почуттів
Зараз ми більше схожі на хороших друзів
ніж на партнерів зараз ми дуже мало
спілкуємося
[музика]
[оплески]
ось я не знаю чи ви це Бачите
якщо ви бачите нашивку з єдинорогом це
означає що перед вами військовий лгбтк
так нашивка з єдинорогом - це ідея
дизайнера лгбтк спільноти вона зробила
цю нашивку тому що багато людей говорили
що в армії немає такого поняття як лгбтк
люди
Ми відчували себе неіснуючими істотами
ніби єдинороги
раніше я уникав цих армійських речей і
знаєте переважно чоловічих спільнот на
кшталт армії чи спортивних клубів
[музика]
початок війни був не таким страшним як
приєднання до армії
[музика]
У нас тут є проблеми нетерпимості
гомофобії
але я очікував що буде гірше
Я маю на увазі що ми не зіштовхувалися з
фізичним насильством Чим більше людей
дізнається про те що в армії є геї тим
толерантнішим стає суспільство
[музика]
якою трагічною Та жахливою не була б
війна вона все одно є дуже сильною
еволюційною річчю
якщо можна так сказати це змушує людей
задуматися про те ким вони є які
цінності вони поділяють
Чи хочуть вони бути з Росією з її
середньовічними цінностями або ж хочуть
бути з демократичними цінностями інших
європейських
країнфест для деяких людей
можуть призвести до більшої
толерантності щодо ЛГБТ та спільноти
вважає Олександр А я тим часом
спробувала дізнатися більше про його
стосунки
[музика]
ти бачиш свого партнера тільки у формі
це може бути фантастично на один день у
цивільному житті але коли це триває 11
місяців без сприймання душу упродовж
чотирьох місяців це зовсім не сексі над
секція
[музика]
Так завтра наша частина наш батальйон
їде у Бахмут
а Бах Я думаю Зараз скрізь у новинах
тому що це одна із найгарячіших і
найнебезпечніших ділянок на лінії фронту
і я не знаю
я справді схвильований
маю на увазі Я впевнений що ми можемо
бути там дуже корисними
після нашої розмови одна фраза
запам'яталася мені Я впевнений що ми
можемо бути там дуже корисними Це мене
дуже налякало Я думаю що реальність в
Україні настільки далека від Західної
Європи народ воює у них зовсім інше
розуміння часу Ось чому він хотів так
швидко з тобою відзняти інтерв'ю страхи
також можуть відігравати іншу роль ви
швидше за все будете їх придушувати
питання яке хвилює всіх в Україні як
Україні найшвидше перемогти і тут у
кожного свій спосіб хтось воює на
передовій хтось на культурному фронті а
хтось роздягається до гулата
використовує еротичні зображення щоб
допомогти Україні перемогти
[музика]
А я вам з ким
Мене звати Настя Я засновник рухотрон
ліфан кожен хто донатить Україні можу
отримати від нас активку це 31 мільйон
482 373 гривні
кожен відповідає за своїх тифк А я що
відповідаю за всіх тих хто анонімно
просто поскидав мені свої активки щоб
вони такі от вам Ой це такий дубки Будь
ласка користуйтеся на благо України
в принципі так мені подобається Та
нічого я зараз займаюсь Тобто це не дуже
сильно відходить до від моїх якихось
моральних в принципі не все інше але
краще я такий цього не робила тобто не
було в мене
потреби
ну взагалі створення торонної фази
почалося на межі
відчаю та жарту коли почалася
повномасштабна коли почалось
сіли налому собі по вину
нести якраз на той момент шукала як
вивести якогось хлопчину з Харкова тобто
що шукала саме машину в неї були там вже
більше 9 на той момент тисяч підписників
в Твіттері то і всі робили хотіли
добавити всі робили репости всі щось там
коментували хотіли допомогти але машина
не знаходилася в якийсь момент вона пише
що типу допис до цього світу той хто
знайде машину тому відправлю цицьку
машини знаходиться за 5 хвилин
[музика]
вимоги до контенту це по-перше ніякого
порнографію тобто ніякої статевих
органів це зазвичай в нас тут да фотки
торсу фотки дупки це все йде про
естетику
є ще варіант скласти
[музика]
офіційно це не законно але ми
намагаємося тримати оту Марку де ми не
переходимо межу між еротикою і
порнографією
[музика]
ми не знаходимо дівчат бо як то кажуть
люди знаходять нас на початку нас було
лише Двоє я і наста а потім приєдналися
доволі доволі швидко Я б сказала бо це
буквально там два-три дні нам вже почали
записувати інші дівчата на той момент
істві блін класний ініціатива я теж так
можу допомогти
[музика]
я вам скажу Так мої друзі які не з нами
зараз тут не знаходяться наприклад в
цьому барі вони не знають Вони не знають
про це рух вони не знають що я там бо
вони не ресорчили а знає з моїх
найближчих це напевно Моя бабуся вона
дізналась самостійно і я думала що вона
припинить зі мною будь-яке спілкування
якось не так прочитає Ну якось так не
так розшифрує подумають що типу Ну
проститутка
але вона виявляється весь цей час
досліджувала Що таке Only Friends куди
ми збираємо пожертви і потім така мені
все що вона мені сказала така Я тебе
підтримую типу ти робиш гарну справу Але
будь ласка сусідці по городу тірає не
кажи нічого Бо вона просто засулить нас
[музика]
осінь
військові в нас зазвичай просять окрім
того що і вони додатять щоб це отримати
вони кажуть Блін це так тупо я до свою
частину ж скидаю але я просто хочу
побачити що це за рух ти пішов ви
скидаєте і
вони всі раді що це ми працюємо Як то
кажуть по всім фронтам і нас називають
хто фронт руху тролі Франції є конкретно
дата смерті на з вами її це так офіційно
вона звучить Коли здохне Путіна але по
факту це коли закінчиться війна
[музика]
якщо пари разом переживають війну то
разом Вони зможуть пережити будь-що
Принаймні я на це Сподіваюся до нових
зустрічей на trucks-іст
А я з ким
сон
[музика]